[Musique]
tant de liens sans de liens nous
unissent ces liens se sont forgés dans
le combat dans les combats des idées
mais aussi dans les épreuves partager
des amis fait le peuple de france vous
êtes le peuple ne pas se mouiller celui
qui ne cède pas vous êtes là dès que
vous vous êtes l'avant ce qui leur est
ficelé
une fois encore
goût et de tombes les pays bas la
république paie de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien nous accueillons eric ciotti
générique que la parole
mes chers amis mes chers compagnons il
me revient le redoutable privilège de
m'exprimer en dernier merci à ceux qui
sont restés merci à ceux qui ne sont pas
parties merci à ceux qui sont restés
fidèles finalement c'est ce que nous
sommes présents fidèles
aujourd'hui mes amis notre famille
politique a rendez vous avec l'histoire
elle a d'abord rendez vous avec son
histoire
une belle et grande histoire dont nous
sommes les héritiers
les héritiers d'une épopée écrite par le
général de gaulle par georges pompidou
par valéry giscard d'estaing par jacques
chirac par nicolas sarkozy ce sont eux
qui nous guide qui balisent notre
parcours ce sont eux qui me guide et qui
constituent mes repères et mes seules
références mes amis certains avaient
déjà publié notre avis de décès
mais nous voilà nous voilà malgré tous
leurs efforts de retour oui la droite
est de retour oui les républicains sont
de retour nous sommes vivants mais
surtout nous sommes debout
merci
merci à christian jacob d'avoir été
l'artisan un la sable infatigable
inépuisable de ce redressement c'est
grâce à toi christian que ce
rassemblement que personne ne prévoyait
s'est installée merci à laurent wauquiez
qui au lendemain de la défaite à
ramasser notre étendard à terre il a
résisté avec force courage aux
dynamiteur de l'intérieur et aux
censeurs de l'extérieur merci à laurent
qui a subi la vindicte de ceux qui le
trouvaient trop à droite mais surtout
pas ces macro nice
oui oui nous sommes là
tellement heureux et je suis tellement
heureux tellement heureux d'être avec
vous tellement heureux d'être ensemble
unie rassemblée unie et rassemblée pour
la victoire oui mes amis notre famille
aujourd'hui à rendez-vous avec son
histoire
mais de façon sans doute plus importante
surtout la france a rendez vous avec sa
grande histoire multiséculaire
la france vient du fond des âges elle
vit l'avenir la pèle mêle demeure elle
même au long du temps écrivait le
général de gaulle oui je crois et j'aime
cette france profondément passionnément
la france du baptême de clovis la france
de jeanne d'arc la france du millénaire
capétiens la france de la révolution
française de valmy des soldats de l'an
ii la france 2 les ondes de l'héroïque
épopée napoléonienne la france
d'austerlitz de cameron la france de la
résistance des marins de l'île de sein
des compagnons de la libération des
maquisards des glières où du limousin la
france grande indépendante de la vème
république
voulu par le général de gaulle contre
les médiocres et petite cuisine
politicienne de la quatrième la france
de jules ferry de clemenceau de malraux
la france de simone veil qui a tant fait
pour les femmes la femme la france la
france de l'esprit des lumières la
france fille aînée de l'église
façonné par ce long manteau d'églises et
de cathédrales
une france
une france qui a offert au monde une
civilisation
mais cette france mes amis n'a jamais
été autant aussi menacé attaqué fracturé
une france qui doute qui hésitent qui se
cherche une france qui a peur
dans la nuit qui semble nous condamner
inexorablement au déclin notre
responsabilité est immense nous sommes
les seuls à pouvoir allumer la lumière
de l'espérance française nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir interrompre le
déclassement d'une nation qui a façonné
l'histoire et éclairer le monde pour
engager ce sursaut un impératif
catégorique s'impose à nous battre
emmanuel macron fossoyeurs de notre
nation mes amis aujourd'hui j'ai une
j'ai une certitude
nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir
remporter l'élection présidentielle face
à lui oui nous pouvons gagner mais
surtout oui nous devons gagner et oui
nous allons gagner
et c'est à vous et quelle magnifique
récompense
militants des républicains
militant de la france qui tenez entre
vos mains la clé de l'avenir de la
nation de notre nation c'est à vous de
décider de choisir qui sera demain le
prochain président de la république
cette france abîmée par le nouveau monde
et son gourou qui a voulu s hypnotiser
le peuple par son narcissisme
il voulait être kennedy 1002 fut que nos
landes bis il se voulait jupiter il
n'aura été que le petit père queuille du
21e siècle il prônait le même temps
apaisant il a fragmenté et dispersé le
pays comme jamais depuis alger où il
accusa de façon ignoble la france de
crimes contre l'humanité jusqu'a l'ombre
où ils dénia l'existence d'une culture
française avant de vouloir déconstruire
notre histoire sur une chaîne de
télévision américaine
partisan d'une nation communautariser
multiculturelle s'enracine apôtre de la
repentance permanente et de la
culpabilisation
systématique président de la lâcheté et
de la soumission face à l'islamisme
tigre de papier don quichotte de
l'inaction
il ne restera finalement de lui que
l'impuissance du verbe et une overdose
de communication il est temps il n'est
que temps de renvoyer le prétendu mozart
de l'économie comme il se présentait il
ya cinq ans à ses gammes mais pour
gagner mes amis
il nous faudra pas seulement dénoncer
les faiblesses les fautes les failles de
nos adversaires elles sont nombreuses il
nous faudra aussi puiser au plus profond
de nous mêmes dans notre histoire dans
notre source dans notre volonté
bref il nous faudra de la fidélité
de la clarté et du courage c'est ce
chemin balisé que je vous propose
d'emprunter ensemble la fidélité oui je
la revendique adhérents au rpr à 16 ans
par amour de la france transmis par un
grand père prisonnier de guerre et est
donc le résistant dans les maquis de
corrèze qui vous et chacun culte sans
limite aux libérateurs de la france
général de gaulle élus de mon village de
montagne saint martin vésubie villa
justes parmi les nations qui a protégé à
l'été 43 des milliers de juifs
admirative de jacques chirac de charles
pasqua de philippe seguin qui ont allumé
en moi la flamme de la france éternelle
oui j'étais fier d'accompagner nicolas
sarkozy toujours
systématiquement oui j'ai été fier
d'avoir été deux fois son porte-parole
lors des élections présidentielles de
2012 et de la primaire de 2016 oui
j'étais fier d'être le secrétaire
général adjoint de nicolas sarkozy chez
les républicains et de lui être toujours
resté fidèle
les soirs de défaite comme les soirs de
victoire et c'est tellement plus facile
oui je voudrais aujourd'hui dire au
président sarkozy
ma reconnaissance
merci monsieur le président pour tout ce
que vous avez apporté à la france
comme vous je n'ai jamais depuis manquer
à l'appel sans état d'âme sans
interruption j'ai été là les soirs de
victoire je le disais comme les soirs de
défaite la clarté ensuite je la
revendique j'ai combattu avec force les
alliances contre nature et vous le savez
notamment dans ma région et dans ma
ville contre ceux qui ont préféré les
places à leurs convictions
c'est plate et on l'a vu cette clarté je
les exprime et au trocadéro au côté de
françois fillon en 2017
on nous avait fustigé
et bien moi je me revendique 2,7 droit
du trocadéro parce que je ne serai
jamais de la droite du mercato qui vend
ses convictions et ses valeurs
oui je le crois j'étais le seul candidat
au congrès présents ce jour là au milieu
de cette foule immense qui refuser
l'injustice et la manipulation je n'ai
pas transiger non plus au second tour de
l'élection prés danse présidentielle oui
je le revendique j'ai refusé de voter
emmanuel macron là encore je suis le
seul candidat au congrès avoir fait ce
choix
et je veux tout de suite
rassuré les commentateurs qui est en
tirer des leçons rapide
je veux dire que j'ai voté au second
tour pour françois baroin mon ami
cette clarté
cette clarté mes amis m'interdit
d'hésiter de reculer de transiger le
courage enfin je le revendique le
courage de la rupture
je veux être aujourd'hui ce candidat du
courage le candidat qui fait tomber les
bastilles du politiquement correct dans
lesquels certains ont voulu nous
enfermer de façon définitive je suis
candidat pour percer les citadelles de
la bien-pensance
avec vous je veux être le candidat qui
renverse la table qui coupent le robinet
d'eau tiède oui je le sais
cette rupture inquiète elle fait peur
quelquefois elle fait peur aux rentiers
du conformisme bousculés dans leurs
habitudes il me rétorque in objecte que
je vais trop loin qu'il ne faut pas
sortir du cadre établi mais mes habits
si on ne prend pas tous les risques
maintenant quand les prendrons nous si
on n'est pas radical maintenant quand le
serons nous certains mre nous condamner
à la prudence la prudence alors comme
décapite sur notre sol un enseignant un
prêtre des chrétiens dans une église de
nice au coeur de ma circonscription
la prudence alors que chaque jour 800
faits de violence gratuite frappe nos
concitoyens la prudence alors que chaque
heure un policier ou un gendarme est
blessé la prudence alors que notre pays
ploie sous 3000 milliards d'euros de
dette la prudence alors que nos dépenses
publiques atteignent des records et
nourrissent des déficits eux aussi
inégalée la prudence alors que nous
comptons cinq millions 600 mille agents
publics soit 2 millions de
fonctionnaires de plus qu en allemagne
la prudence alors que des retraités sont
obligés de se nourrir dans les
restaurants du coeur après avoir
travaillé durement toute une vie la
prudence
la prudence alors que deux millions
d'étrangers sont rentrés en france au
cours des cinq dernières années
ignorant nos valeurs nos cultures et
considérant pour beaucoup que leurs
règles leurs coutumes ou leurs lois
religieuses étaient supérieures aux lois
de la république
la prudence alors que des centaines de
quartiers sont aujourd'hui tenues par
les islamistes et par les
narcotrafiquants selon la formule de
gérard collomb que les dealers y érige
comme à marseille des checkpoints comme
à beyrouth où comme à damas la prudence
alors que la france est championne du
monde des impôts et des taxes qui
accable tous ceux qui travaillent ou ont
travaillé durement toute une vie la
prudence alors que notre industrie
disparaît que nos hôpitaux sont en crise
que notre système de santé périclite que
le niveau scolaire s'effondre que des
territoires entiers se paupérise non mes
amis la prudence est un luxe que notre
pays n'a plus les moyens de s'offrir et
bien pour moi et bien pour moi l'heure
n'est plus à la prudence et leur ne peut
plus être à la prudence l'heure doit
être au dépassement
vivre c'est ne pas se résigner écrivait
camus mon diagnostic est sans concession
certes car je ne veux laisser place
laissé aucune place au doute ou à
l'hésitation cette rupture nous elle
doit s'incarner dans la force d'un
projet puissant de renaissance de la
nation française je me présente
aujourd'hui devant vous avec un projet
audacieux
responsable chiffre est solide le seul à
même j'en suis profondément
convaincu de redresser la france ce
projet avec ses 150 propositions je
voulais adresser je voulais transféré
pour que vous l'approprier pour que vous
en fassiez vous en fassiez l'ambassadeur
ce projet mes amis il est à droite et je
ne m'en excuserai jamais il est à droite
tout simplement pour que la france reste
la france
il repose sur trois piliers porteurs
l'autorité
l'identité et la liberté oui mon projet
rétablir à l'autorité il restera l'ordre
républicain par l'impunité zéro il
protégera nos policiers par les peines
plancher ce qui touche à un uniforme de
la république devront recevoir un
message simple le soir même ils
dormiront en prison
mon projet en fermera les islamistes il
sacralise ras la propriété privée contre
les squats il expulsera les criminels et
les délinquants étrangers qui occupe
aujourd'hui 25% des places de nos
prisons pour eux le message sera clair
ce sera la prison et l'avion mon projet
mon projet préservera mon projet
préservera notre identité en incarnant
la fierté d'un peuple qui refuse de
disparaître il combattra le walkie sme
qui veut déboulonner nos statuts et
l'écriture inclusive qui veut des
construire notre langue est ce que nous
sommes
il inscrira il inscrira nos racines
judéo chrétiennes dans la constitution
française
il interdira il interdira le voile
islamique
prison de soumission pour les femmes
pour les fillettes et pour les usagers
du service public
il arrêtera la folie du regroupement
familial illimitée il reste aura le
droit du sang pour qu'on ne devienne
plus français par le fruit du hasard il
n'y aura plus de droit l'immigration
plus aucune tolérance pour les
clandestins dans notre pays il n'y aura
qu'un droit celui de la nation à choisir
qui elle souhaite accueillir chez elle
ce ne sera plus ce ne sera plus à la
france de s'adapter à des cultures et
des modes de vie qui ne sont pas fidèles
à notre histoire je le dis simplement ce
sera à ceux qui ont l'honneur d'être
accueillis en france de se conformer à
ce qu'est la france le message doit être
entendu reçu du monde entier en france
on vit comme des français
mon projet remplacera le ministère de
l'éducation nationale au profit d'un
ministère de l'instruction nationale il
tournera le dos à une europe fédérale et
technocratique pour refonder l'europe
des nations et des peuples tel que
l'avait avec lucidité dessinée philippe
seguin il conduira
enfin
troisième pilier porter après l'autorité
là et cette identité
mon projet refondre à nos libertés
je le dis et plus que jamais aujourd'hui
il sera fidèle à celui de françois
fillon pour réformer la france il
conduira une véritable révolution
fiscale en baissant massivement les
impôts il supprimera l'impôt sur la mort
l'impôt sur les successions et les
donations pour les patrimoines en deçà
de 5 millions d'euros il libéra la
france de la bureaucratie il réduira
massivement les dépenses publiques
réduira le nombre d'agents publics il
rétablira la retraite à 65 ans et les 39
heures il supprimera l'enchevêtrement
territoriales bref il nous fera
économiser 100 milliards d'euros
d'argent public sur le quinquennat
il récompensera le travail et le mérite
au détriment de l'assistanat et donnera
une nouvelle espérance à notre jeunesse
il restera le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
en procédant à l'indexation des
retraites en rétablissant la demi part
pour les veuves et en introduisant un
minimum retraite à hauteur du smic il
nous rendra aussi une liberté une
indépendance énergétique en luttant
contre le changement climatique menace
cruciales par le progrès la science et
le nucléaire il soutiendra l'esprit
d'entreprendre en soutenant et en créant
des richesses il soutiendra les chefs
d'entreprise les artisans les
commerçants
oui mes amis mes compagnons et ce mot
christian un sens très fort pour nous
oui mais à vie je vous invite à franchir
le pont d'arcole ne vous résignez pas ce
congrès vous appartient alors prenez le
pouvoir voter pour vos idées fait gagner
la france tel le maréchal leclerc qui a
prêté le serment de koufra jurant de ne
jamais cesser le combat tant que le
drapeau français ne faudrait pas sur la
cathédrale de strasbourg
ensemble prétend le serment de conduire
le combat des idées jusqu'à ce que nos
couleurs flottent sur la france et sur
l'elysée jusqu'à la victoire
ensemble uni rassemblé tout redeviendra
possible pour que la france reste la
france
bien
merci
même si cher eric aux bonnes entames
cette dernière série de questions je
voulais te poser la question sur
l'écriture inclusive avec l'apparition
dans le dictionnaire le robert cette
semelle du pronom ne nous prônons neutre
yahiel mais comme tu as parlé de lait
des ravages de l'écriture inclusive de
la propagation du oak hills mme de la
déconstruction générale de tout cela je
vais pas t'interroger sur sur ces
questions auxquelles tu as réfléchis
tu as dit au moment des débats il faut
qu'on remédie au craf problème que tu as
fort bien décrit quoi qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte est ce que tu peux
nous dire ce que tu entendez par là ce
quoi qu'il en coûte est-ce que tu songes
et aux difficultés qui sont les nôtres
en matière de juridiction nationale ou
communautaire le conseil d'état le
conseil constitutionnel la cour de
justice européenne la cour des droits de
l'homme la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme est ce que c'est à cela que tu
pensais auquel tu voulais
remédier dans leurs oeufs dans leurs
possibilités d'empêchement à décider
est-ce que tu penser à d'autres choses
que tu nous en dire un peu plus merci
annie merci aussi pour la présidence du
conseil national sur la grille tueur
inclusif j'en ai parlé mais quand même
un mot qui est assez révélateur du
double langage de ce pouvoir nous avons
la ministre de l'egalité madame moreno à
ne pas confondre avec une voyelle qui
distingue tous chers nadine
madame moreno
qui nous dit que ce pronom a-elle
la fusion de l'homme et d'une femme et
bien c'est bienvenu qu'on l'inscrivent
dans le petit robert et puis nous avons
les pousses du président de la
république qui nous dit l' inverse c'est
assez révélateur de ce discours
contradictoire où on parle à des
clientèles et où on ne parle pas à la
france où on n'a pas de conviction mais
ouanna simplement une attitude de
communication
voilà pour le nucléaire dans le discours
du candidat macron contre le nucléaire
dans l'action du président macron pour
la réforme des retraites dans le
discours du candidat macron mais
l'immobilisme pour réformer les
retraites de la part du président macron
voilà à nice qu'est ce que je voulais
dire par ce quoi qu'il en coûte
sécuritaire je voulais dire que l'état
doit retrouver sa force l'autorité
républicaine doit retrouver sa place
l'ordre doit être rétabli en france et
personnellement je n'accepte pas qu'il y
ait des centaines de quartiers
aujourd'hui qu'ils soient laissées aux
mains des trafiquants de drogue ou
qu'ils soient laissées aux mains des
islamistes alors demain il faudra
mobiliser tous les moyens
toutes les volontés
celle de la police celle de la
gendarmerie celle de la justice mais
aussi s'il le faut comme c'est déjà le
cas pour nous prévenir du terrorisme
avec la force sentinelle celle de
l'armée et il faut savoir que ceux qui
sont en face ceux qui sont en face ceux
qui défient la république seront
poursuivis quoi qu'il leur en coûte
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que des
policiers reçoivent des instructions
pour ne pas rentrer dans les cités pour
ne pas poursuivre les rodéos pour ne pas
créer des tensions qui seraient
susceptibles de soulever des brasiers et
bien je le dis à un moment il faudra
prendre nos responsabilités il faudra
dire ça suffit il n'y a pas de
territoire étranger en terre de france
il n'y a pas d'autres lois que celles de
la république en terre de france
cher eric je m'apprêtais à s'interroger
sur la question de l'immigration mais il
me semble que tu as été suffisamment
clair pour que je t'ai interroge sur un
autre sujet je voudrais parler de
liberté nous sommes un grand pays qui a
toujours aimé la liberté tu le sais il
n'y a pas d'ordre sans liberté le
rétablissement de l'ordre sans le
rétablissement et la préservation des
libertés ne s'appelle pas la république
tout comme il n'y a pas et tu l'as dit
de courage sans liberté ce qui a guidé
le général de gaulle était autant
l'amour de la france que l'amour de la
liberté ce qui a guidé les grands
progrès dans notre famille politique a
été les porter tu as cité simone veil
tout à l'heure c'était autant le goût du
courage que le coût de la liberté en
l'occurrence la liberté des femmes ce
qui a guidé jacques chirac lorsqu'il a
fait entendre la voix de la france face
aux états unis d'amérique c'était autant
le goût du courage le goût de la france
que le goût de la liberté ces libertés
depuis deux ans elles sont abîmées
chacun portera les jugements qu'il veut
sur la situation sanitaire mais nous ne
pouvons pas oublier que nous sortirons
dans quelques mois nous l'espérons de
deux années durant lesquelles nos
libertés publiques nos libertés
individuelles ont été abîmés l'enjeu de
la liberté c'est autant le libéralisme
économique que le libéralisme des
libertés individuelles comment demain
nous la droite républicaine nous pouvons
retrouver un discours qui porte qui a
toujours été le nôtre qui est celui de
la reconstruction du rétablissement et
la préservation des libertés publiques
et des libertés individuelles
merci aurélien notre famille politique
tu l'a rappelé a permis quelques unes
des plus grandes avancées vers la
liberté et la vème république
anne est une des plus grandes avancées
je le dis en le remerciant et en le
saluant sous le contrôle du président du
sénat notre ami gérard larcher qui est
dans cette haute assemblée le garant
aussi de la défense de nos libertés
pour moi la liberté
c'est l'esprit des lumières qui a
éclairé le monde et qui doit être
préservée c'est ce message universel de
la france est pour moi la liberté elle
doit aussi s'associer à l'indépendance
ce message il le sera d'autant plus fort
et ça a été dit ce matin que nous serons
exemplaire que notre comportement sera
exemplaire alors oui il faut bien sûr se
battre de façon incessante pour la
liberté mais je le dis aussi et c'est
peut-être une nuance je fais partie de
ceux qui croient aux progrès en la
science et j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
ont voté le pass sanitaire je le dis
parce que je ne me reconnais pas dans
une forme de regards complotistes ou
exclure antiste je crois que personne ne
veut aujourd'hui remettre en cause la
sécurité de nos concitoyens et que le
devoir d'une famille responsable parce
que demain nous aurons aussi à diriger
l'état et nous aurons peut-être à faire
face à des crises aussi sévère c'est de
dire la vérité est d'avoir une attitude
de responsabilité je veux aussi dire que
la liberté individuelle à laquelle je
crois elle doit aussi s'inscrire dans
cette théorie de l' équilibre entre la
liberté collective et la liberté
individuelle
aujourd'hui trop souvent les arbitrages
venue de cour de justice européenne de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais aussi il faut le reconnaître du
conseil constitutionnel ou du conseil
d'état ou de la cour de cassation ont
privilégié la liberté individuelle au
détriment de la liberté de la
collectivité de la liberté de tous
lorsque le conseil constitutionnel
gérard a censuré la loi que nous avions
fait voter j'avais déposé un amendement
au sénat à l'assemblée nationale pardon
et le sénat naturellement avait fait
voter ce texte qui permettait de
pénaliser la consultation des sites
jihadistes et bien le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré en indiquant
que la liberté individuelle
était supérieur à la sécurité collective
je n'ai pas cette approche de la
situation
la sécurité collective aujourd'hui doit
être la première des libertés et il faut
le dire elle n'est plus garantie de même
quand le conseil constitutionnel censure
la loi qui permettait de mettre quelques
petits dispositifs bien modeste au
demeurant de contrôle des 2540
islamistes ou terroristes islamistes qui
sont sortis depuis 2018 et qui sortiront
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 de prison
le conseil constitutionnel a censuré en
disant que là aussi la liberté de ces
personnes primées sur la sécurité de la
société et bien je le dis ce n'est pas
ma conception aussi bien sur la liberté
elle doit s'affirmer et elle ne doit
plus aujourd'hui c'est s'attaquer à ceux
qui entreprennent qui travaille avec
courage avec force pour moi la liberté
c'est aussi et c'est d'abord et je les
dis la liberté d'entreprendre la liberté
de gagner plus avec son travail qu'avec
le fruit de l'assistance la liberté de
pouvoir créer imaginer de soutenir nos
chargeurs de soutenir nos médecins de
soutenir la science le progrès c'est
aussi cela le souffle de la liberté d'un
grand pays mais ne soyons pas naïfs
aujourd'hui nous savons où sont nos
ennemis nous savons qui nous a déclaré
une guerre de civilisation
nous savons qu'ils veulent nous détruire
ne soyons pas naïfs
sachant nous protéger et imposant aussi
une liberté collective le droit à la
société de se protéger contre ce de
façon individuelle qui veulent l'attaqué
bien
alors première question les microbes le
oui bonjour monsieur le député je me
présente florent aussi délégué des
jeunes républicains du 7e arrondissement
de paris aux côtés de rachida dati je
voudrais vous interroger sur la
situation dans universités françaises et
sur la jeunesse de notre pays le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron aura été
marquée par le mépris envers nos
universités la crise sanitaire elle a
révélé toutes les inégalités et tous les
problèmes qui touchent les étudiants et
qui touche les universités en france et
la crise sanitaire elle aura aussi
révélé l'existence d'une ministre
fantone frédéric vidal dandonneau
souviendront par son silence et par son
mépris envers nos universités alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est face à deux problèmes
majeurs de problèmes majeurs qui sont en
train de s'aggraver à savoir la baisse
du niveau et à savoir la propagation
d'idéologie absolument mortifère à
l'image de la grande scène culture ou
d'humo qui sme donc c'est vrai que le
niveau baisse par rapport à nos voisins
européens dans les universités et c'est
vrai que toutes ces idéologies se
propage à une vitesse grand v donc ma
question elle est double j'ai envie de
vous demander comment comptez vous
redresser le niveau de nos universités
françaises et nos écoles françaises et
comment comptez vous lutter contre
toutes ces idéologies délirante je vous
remercie
merci
ma réponse pourrait se résumer à votre
question tellement elle est pleine de
bon sens moi je ne suis pas adepte de
déboulonner nos statuts je ne souhaite
pas comme le président de la république
on déconstruisent notre histoire je ne
souhaite pas que l'on juge avec les
valeurs d'aujourd'hui l'histoire d'il ya
plusieurs siècles où il ya plusieurs
millénaires
cette théorie se moque isme set quand
celle culture qui veut effacer ce que
nous sommes et bien c'est d'abord il
faut le dire une nouvelle forme de
totalitarisme
d'extrémisme qui veut imposer à l'égal
du stalinisme dont il est quelque part
l'héritier une nouvelle tyrannie et bien
sachant combattre cette tyrannie et moi
j'ai mal à ma france quand je vois dans
une école dont j'ai été diplômé sciences
po que l'on refuse aujourd'hui
d'accueillir tel ou tel parce qu'il
serait porteur d'une idéologie qui n'est
pas fidèle à la vision d'extrême gauche
qui est aujourd'hui porté par une
minorité mais une minorité puissante je
le disais tout à l'heure sachant nous
affranchir de ses frontières du
politiquement correct qui ont été
dessinés avec le camp du bien le camp du
mal et bien aujourd'hui il faudra du
courage il faudra de la force il faudra
abattre ces totems c'est tabou ce
politiquement correct qui aujourd'hui
stérilise l'action publique paralyse les
discours et qu'il quelquefois à même
entraver la course de notre famille
politique
oui il faudra du courage il faudra
balayer ces oppositions ces théories
n'ont rien à faire à l'université elles
n'ont pas plus à faire dans l'école de
la république
quand je vois qu'on a rédigé à
destination des enseignants une
circulaire sur les problématiques liées
aux enfants transgenres ces
problématiques tels peuvent exister et
je ne les conteste pas mais elle relève
de la famille et elles ne relèvent en
rien de l'école de la république
arrêtons de tout mélanger posons
aujourd'hui des garde-fous contre ces
théories délirante et puis vous avez
parlé de la jeunesse si nous sommes ici
c'est pour vous d'abord je veux dire
combien il est important d'avoir avec le
relief et christian avec dilemme carayon
redonner une force un magnifique
mouvement de jeunesse il faut qu'on
fasse le pari de la jeunesse il faut
qu'on donne à la jeunesse l'amour de la
france moi je suis malheureux quand je
vois que cette jeunesse pourquoi on en
est arrivé là pourquoi on veut des
construire notre histoire parce qu'il ya
un président de la république qui accuse
en permanence la france est plus aussi
disons le parce que notre école son
modèle d'intégration d'assimilation
il ne fonctionne plus il est en panne
quand je vois que dans certaines
rencontres de football qui oppose la
france un pays étranger en l'occurrence
un pays maghrébin des français des
jeunes français juridiquement français
qui ont eu la nationalité française et
c'est pour cela que je suis contre le
droit du sol et bien préfère brandir un
drapeau étranger plutôt qu'un drapeau
français oui on se dit aujourd'hui qu'il
est nécessaire de redonner un sens à
notre modèle d'assimilation et
d'intégration et de donner une nouvelle
et une grande espérance à la jeunesse et
puis je crois qu'il faut aider aussi
cette jeunesse il faut des écoles des
universités qui leur transmettent une
formation qui va leur ouvrir les clés de
l'emploi qu'elle mais quelle folie ce
rsa jeunes quel regard méprisant sur la
jeunesse mais quelle erreur qu'elle
flotte lourde de dix rangs jeunes au
lieu de l'inciter à se former à
travailler à travailler dur comme
beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont fait de lui
dire que le premier geste pour entrer
dans la vie active sera de recevoir une
allocation moi je ne serai pas le
candidat qui versent des primes des
allocations moi je veux être celui qui
valorise le travail l'énergie qui baisse
les impôts et qui donne sa chance à ceux
qui travaillent c'est cette espérance
que l'on doit donner à la jeunesse de
france
bien merci alors le micro
rouge orange orange par orange voilà
bonjour monsieur ciotti je suis né vers
lauga du coup rdj du 04 et conseiller
national alors ma question je les écris
parce que ça fait un moment que vous en
parler ça fait un moment que je voulais
avoir plus d'explications vous proposez
une mesure que je trouve plus que
salvatrice pour la propriété privée
notamment pour les jeunes et je voulais
savoir si vous pouviez nous en dire plus
sur les bienfaits de l'exonération des
droits de succession et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs de nous proposer cette mesure
qui normalement devraient être repris
par l'ensemble de la droite
nous à nous en débattions ensemble ce
que nous sommes 5
et quoi qu'il arrive je veux le dire
nous serons tous unis et rassemblés et
pour moi cette mesure elle est
essentielle je veux qu'on supprime les
droits de succession et les droits de
donations en ligne directe parce que
pour moi ces impôts sont des impôts sur
la mort alors toute une vie vous avez
payé une multitude d'impôt l'impôt sur
le revenu la tva la csg les taxes
locales et taxes sur le carburant ô
combien lourde lorsque vous voulez
transmettre en quittant cette terre ou
en préparant cette perspective à vos
enfants eh bien l'état confiscatoire
arrivent et ils vous prélève le fruit du
travail de toute une vie quelquefois
jusqu'à la moitié
c'est un pot pour moi il est
profondément injuste
la mouette presque la moitié des pays de
l' ocde l'on supprimé et ceux qui ne
l'ont pas supprimé et appliquent des
taux extrêmement faible en italie le
taux de 4% hors ne s'applique à partir
d'un abattement d'un million d'euros
c'est cent mille euros pour nous en
france tous les 15 ans donc oui je
souhaite qu'on supprime l'impôt sur la
mort je supprime l'impôt sur les
successions sur les donations et je
souhaite et ça rejoint la question
précédente sur les jeunes qu'on lance
aussi une mesure très symbolique de
transfert de mobilité du capital
financier vers la jeunesse je propose
que les grands parents puissent donner
immédiatement en franchise d'impôt
jusqu'à cent cinquante mille euros à
leurs petits enfants aujourd'hui il y a
cinq mille 700 milliards d'euros
d'épargné stériliser sur les comptes sur
les livres et des français ça s'est
accentué durant la crise sanitaire où la
consommation a été plus faible et bien
je le dis quel meilleur plan de relance
que celui qui permettrait d'assurer la
mobilité de cette épargne financière
stériliser de l'orienter vers ceux qui
ont envie de créer pour acheter un petit
appartement un premier logement pour la
jeunesse pour créer une entreprise pour
prendre des risques c'est cela qui
constituerait le plus grand plan de
relance imaginé que sur les cinq mille
700 milliards d'euros on arrive en
débloquer 1 % cela représenterait 50 7
milliards d'euros mise au service d'un
grand plan de relance pour la france et
pour la première fois parce qu'il faut
arrêter avec la logique des dépenses
publiques qui aujourd'hui gangrène notre
pays dès qu'il ya un problème dès qu'il
ya une crise on sort un chèque en sort
une mesure on sort une prime mais cet
argent d'où il vient il ne tombe pas du
ciel en pluie fine il vient d'une poche
pour la mettre dans une autre est
généralement l'argent public il est pris
dans la poche droite pour la mettre dans
la poche gauche est l'exemple il n'est
pas pris au hasard alors oui je le dis
il faut que demain au nez ce plan de
relance qui assure cette mobilité fins
de l'impôt sur les successions impôt
injuste et impôt inefficace au plan
économique parce qu'il gèle et
patrimoine et puis c'est un peu aussi il
est contraire à tout ce que je crois moi
je crois ce beau mot de transmission la
transmission de nos valeurs de notre
histoire à nos enfants et quand on
transmet un bien quand on transmet une
pierre de la pierre un bâtiment qui a
été quelquefois fabriqués par le fruit
de toute une vie et bien ce bien il
représentent des valeurs il représente
l'histoire d'une famille on veut le
protéger on veut le préserver on veut le
transmettre plus grand plus beau plus
fort à ses enfants c'est ça l'histoire
et c'est ça le progrès et c'est ça le
pont entre les valeurs et les
générations
messi alors monsieur
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur qui
conseil national du nord à valenciennes
on a parlé de la ville de pikine est
donc ma question est double à comment
allez-vous faire un référendum sur des
peines par exemple les délinquants qui
quitta base des policiers des élus des
forces de l'ordre et aussi allez vous
faire aussi comment allez vous les
mettre en prison le soir même alors que
les prisons sont pleines
comment allez-vous faire
il faut il faudra réformer notre
constitution nous l'avons dit tous et je
crois que nous sommes tous d'accord moi
je propose d'abord un référendum au
titre de l'article 11 c'est celui qui
est entre les mains du président de la
république c'est celui que le général de
gaulle a utilisé deux fois en mettant en
cause d'ailleurs sa responsabilité en
1962 pour créer le suffrage universel et
en 1969 sur la réforme territoriale
qu'il a perdu et dont il a tiré les
conséquences je proposerai cet article
11 le même jour que les élections
législatives pour faire en sorte que la
france recouvre sa souveraineté
juridique qu'elle a perdu aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas mettre en place ces peines
plancher comme on ne peut pas supprimer
le regroupement familial où on ne peut
pas procéder à l'expulsion d'étrangers
terroristes dangereux dans notre pays
pourquoi parce que nous sommes soumis à
des traités à des conventions notamment
dans le cadre européen qui sont
supérieures aux lois de la république
pas supérieur à la constitution mais
supérieur aux lois de la république
c'est l'article 55 de notre constitution
je propose qu'on le modifie
immédiatement le même jour que les
élections législatives
et je propose ensuite que pendant tout
l'été 2022 une fois que cette réforme
aura été opéré et bien nous modifions
par la loi tous les points de blocage
qui nous appellent d'agir il faut que
l'on retrouve notre souveraineté
juridique il faut que la france décide
de son destin moi je ne peux pas
accepter que la cour de justice de
l'union européenne viennent nous dire à
nos armées qu'elles ne pourront pas
travailler plus de 35 heures ce n'est
pas supportable ce n'est pas acceptable
moi je refuse que la cour de justice de
l'union européenne viennent remettre en
cause le modèle de sécurité civile qui a
fait la force de la france avec larry
mize ac qui désormais peut interdire un
sapeur pompier volontaire de travailler
parallèlement à ces vacations de sapeurs
pompiers il faut que sur les questions
de sécurité nationale de défense
nationale d'immigration la france
recouvre le cours de son destin je le
disais dans mon propos il y a des droits
il ya même un code des étrangers le
droit à l'asile le droit à étudier le
droit au regroupement familial
et bien moi je souhaite domaine qu'il
n'y ait qu'un droit le droit de la
france à choisir qui elle souhaite ou
pas accueillir sur le sol national
quant à la méthode la méthode elle est
clair comment on restaurera l'ordre
républicain vous savez je sais que c'est
une source d'inspiration fertile j'ai
travaillé avec patrick stefanini
d'ailleurs au programme de françois
fillon en 2017 j'avais déposé une grande
loi une proposition de loi d'orientation
et de programmation sur la sécurité
intérieure et la justice tout ll y ait
un engagement budgétaire pluriannuel sur
cinq ans cinq milliards d'euros de plus
par an une réforme de la réponse pénale
est d'abord une augmentation de nos
capacité carcérale il y a aujourd'hui 62
mille places de prison je souhaite qu'en
2027 en année cent mille je souhaite
qu'on multiplie par deux les centres
éducatifs fermés pour placer les mineurs
délinquants je souhaite qu'on rétablisse
la loi qui porte mon nom qui permettait
un encadrement militaire pour les
mineurs délinquants dans les epide et
qui a été supprimée par madame taubira
par monsieur hollande et par monsieur
macron donc il faut un engagement
budgétaire il faut des moyens
supplémentaires que nos policiers ne
roule plus dans des véhicules de plus
300 mille kilomètres que les bâtiments
de la république soient dignes et
respectés mais qu'il y ait cette réponse
pénale je les dis protéger l'uniforme de
la république avec ses peines minimales
tels que rachida dati et nicolas sarkozy
les avait bâti pour les
multirécidivistes
s'il ya la volonté tout de suite on peut
changer beaucoup de choses simplement je
le redis si on donne les instructions
d'abattre les checkpoints physique et
immatériel qui nous empêchent de rentrer
dans les quartiers alors oui il faudra y
aller de toutes nos forces et avec
courage parce que bien sûr ça va bouger
bien sûr ça va tanguer mais il faut le
dire avant pour ne pas reculer après je
le dis avec force
le micro je dis s'il vous plaît
monsieur se dit bonjour je suis pire la
faune je viens de haute-garonne je suis
conseiller municipal et communautaire
je connais votre engagement local comme
président du conseil départemental
député et on retient aussi ce que vous
avez fait pour saint martin vésubie
récemment avec les catastrophes qui a eu
là bas
alors
aujourd'hui on sait que les citoyens ne
font plus confiance quand leur mère
pourtant ils ont de moins en moins de
pouvoir il ne les citoyennes vont pas
voter aux élections départementales
régionales
vous avez aussi souligné le trop plein
de fonctionnaires qu'il y ait en france
alors ma question c'est comment vous
attaquer au millefeuille administratif
lorsque vous serez au pouvoir merci
alors j'ai une proposition je vous ai
dit que j'étais pas adepte de l'eau
tiède que je portais un projet de
rupture je vais sans doute
soulever quelques oppositions
moi j'ai je souhaite une réforme
radicale de notre organisation
territoriale
je souhaite que demain il n'y ait plus
que deux échelons territoriaux la
commune cellule de base de la démocratie
adn de la république qui est le fruit de
ces siècles d'histoire que j'évoquais la
commune ou sur chaque place figure un
clocher un monument aux morts qui porte
le nom de ceux qui ont fait le sacrifice
suprême pour nos libertés la façade de
la mairie sur laquelle flotte le drapeau
tricolore c'est notre communauté de base
celle où chacun se retrouve se reconnaît
et se rassemblent pendant les crises
cette commune ces communes elles ont été
affaibli notamment par le développement
acharné de collectivités hors sol imposé
par des règles technocratiques et très
souvent politicienne je pense notamment
aux métropoles qui ne correspondent en
rien à la réalité de notre histoire et
qui ont construit un écrin échelons
extraordinairement coûteux et qui
complexifie l'organisation territoriale
je le vis dans mon territoire où une
métropole a été créé où son président
revendique d'être à la tête de douze
mille fonctionnaires ce qui l'a conduit
à augmenter la dette jusqu'à 2 milliards
d'euros et d'être au final contraint de
créer un nouvel impôt qui s'appelle
l'impôt métropolitain qui a augmenté
jusqu'à 15 % la taxe foncière eh bien ça
je n'en veux plus je le dis très
clairement et je souhaite je souhaite je
souhaite qu'au dessus et bien il y ait
une super collectivité mais plus qu'une
et je m'en excuse auprès de xavier et de
valérie mais peut-être que sur l'île de
france on a une spécificité bien sûr
particulière et l'intuition de nicolas
sarkozy du grand paris n'était pas une
fois cette mission quand on voit
quelques coupures s'introduit
aujourd'hui entre ceux qui n'ont pas le
privilège de vivre à l'intérieur de
paris mais qui travaillent et les
contraintes valérie qu'on impose à ceux
qui sont à l'extérieur avec des règles
qui sont celles de lobby et de l'uby
écologistes alors moi je le dis je
souhaite je souhaite qu'il y ait au
dessus de la commune une super
collectivités que j'appelle province qui
reprendrait tous les pouvoirs des
départements des régions et des
métropoles une collectivité souple qui
ré de cinq cent mille à 2 millions et
demi d'habitants c'est à dire les plus
gros département qui existent
aujourd'hui qui correspondrait à une
histoire et qui permettrait d'être
beaucoup plus efficace d'économiser de
l'argent public d'être une collectivité
de proximité est passé les régions
immenses immense comme aurélien cette
nouvelle oxis et occitanie où cette
nouvelle aquitaine depuis bayonne
jusqu'à guéret et guillaume qui a aucune
cohérence c'est cela qu'il faut revoir
et entre les deux et entre les deux
gérard il faudrait qu'il y ait des
intercommunalités de projets librement
choisis par les maires mais rien
d'imposé voilà ma vision de la nouvelle
architecture territoriale de la france
ça a été dit tout à l'heure chacun tous
ceux qui ce sont eux qui ont osé
réformer ils ont construit un échelon
sans supprimer un autre je souhaite
aussi que dans cette province et bien il
y un conseiller territorial élu sur un
territoire qui puisse siéger dans ces
assemblées et qu'ils soient tout autant
représentants des populations que des
territoires parce que le redécoupage des
cantons qu'a t'il eu comme conséquence
il a affaibli la ruralité il a méprisé
cette france des territoires et il
aboutit à un regard qui n'est que celui
des grandes villes et des grandes
métropoles au détriment de ses trois
mille petites communes qui dessine cette
mosaïque tricolore qui fait la france
merci
alors le micro bleus s'il vous plaît
merci bonjour donc moi je me présente je
suis conseiller national de l'aisne donc
j'ai 28 ans et je m'appelle cédric saint
sulpice donc moi théoriquement grâce à
la république je me suis levé
socialement je viens des quartiers
populaires notamment de saint denis
après mes parents se sont exilés en
picardie et notamment à villers
cotterêts donc moi
estime légitime de donner de mon temps
parce que j'ai quand même obtenu un bac
en finale bac + 5 en finance donc
j'accorde énormément de temps dans des
lycées assez précaire notamment en
difficulté comme à soissons je donne de
mon temps et je peux vous garantir que
quand j'ai changé avec cette une partie
de cette jeunesse il ya de grosses
grosses difficultés et surtout un
certain désamour pour notre république
et notamment la france donc moi je
voulais savoir comment allez vous faire
pour réconcilier cette partie de la
jeunesse qui est de plus en plus
violente qui croient que le rap au lieu
de le prendre comme un divertissement le
prends comme la réalité que prendre la
réelle et à la télé réalité comme du
divertissement ils le prennent pour de
la réalité encore une fois comment allez
vous faire pour réconcilier une partie
de cette jeunesse qui est de plus en
plus violente qui n'a plus aucun respect
pour certaines valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et pour leur apprendre à les
mettre le pied à l'étrier lors dire qu'
il ya un pays à une nation qu'il faut la
respecter qu'il faut se mettre au
travail et sortir même sur la difficulté
qu'on peut enfin même si on a des
difficultés difficulté pardon qu'on peut
s'en sortir
la réponse
la réponse pour moi elle porte le nom de
la famille de l'école de la loi de la
république de l'autorité g à la demande
de nicolas sarkozy
en 2010 fait voter une loi et qui porte
mon nom et qui permettait de restaurer
l'autorité parentale l'autorité
parentale elle est inscrite dans le code
civil et les parents qui ne
respecteraient pas cette autorité
parentale ils peuvent être sanctionnées
cette fois par le code pénal donc je
crois qu'on doit convoquer aujourd'hui
la responsabilité parentale
kombouare réhabiliter l'autorité
parentale c'est pour ça que je disais
tout à l'heure que il doit y avoir le
ministère de l'instruction nationale qui
transmet des savoirs qui transmet
l'apprentissage de l'histoire de france
mais il doit y avoir aussi la famille on
doit pouvoir aller regarder quand un
mineur délinquant est arrêté 30 50 fois
à un moment on doit pouvoir convoquer
cette famille on doit pouvoir lui dire
aussi que si elle a des droits elle doit
aussi avoir des devoirs et qu'il n'est
pas forcément systématique et
obligatoire que l'on reçoive des
allocations familiales
ces enfants ne sont pas éduqués et s'il
ne fréquentent pas les bancs de la
république c'est une réponse ensuite il
y à un gigantesque travail sur l'école
c'est sans doute les défis sont
multiples on l'a dit ça a été dit je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord il faudra
refonder cette école de la république il
faudra redonner aussi aux enseignants la
considération qu'il mérite il faudra
rééquilibrer les effectifs on en parlait
tout à l'heure un million cent mille
agents dans l'éducation nationale il y
en a que 75% qui enseignent des
consignes et des concours pour intégrer
l'éducation nationale dont le niveau
s'effondrer qui a pour conséquence que
le niveau scolaire lui aussi s'effondre
donc il faut réhabiliter les fonctions
d'enseignement il faut peut-être des
modes de recrutement diversifié plus
ouvert sur l'entreprise il faut une
formation continue il faut casser avec
ses moule idéologique
aussi il faut le dire donc il faudra
reconstruire cette école de la
république et puis je souhaite parce que
nous avons besoin d'un gigantesque
modèle d'assimilation à la république
j'ai eu le privilège c'est assez rare
dans cette majorité très sectaire de
pouvoir faire adopter un amendement qui
rend obligatoire la présence du drapeau
français dans chaque classe de chaque
école de chaque collège de chaque lycée
de la république il faut simplement il
faut que ce modèle d'intégration
d'assimilation fasse aimer la france à
notre jeunesse là est essentielle mais
pour qu'on transmettre l'amour de la
france encore faut-il aimer soi même la
france croire qu'elle a des racines
croire qu'elle a une histoire croire
qu'elle a un avenir et arrêter de la
fustiger en permanence
un mot de conclusion générique il te
reste un peu plus d'une minute nous
achèverons ce conseiller nazaire si mes
chers amis pour votre votre patience
vous êtes resté resté fidèle et je leur
dis c'était mon mot d'introduction mais
pour moi l'engagement la fidélité la
fidélité à un autre histoire la fidélité
à nos valeurs elle est importante je
suis engagé dans ce combat dans cette
compétition et qui est une compétition
qui porte des valeurs d'unité de
rassemblement et qui doit garantir à la
sortie l'unité le rassemblement parce
que j'aime la france parce que j'aime
passionnément mon pays que ce pays est
un beau et grand pays et que nous sommes
les héritiers d'une famille politique
qui a écrit les plus belles pages de
cette histoire de france et aujourd'hui
j'ai mal à ma france je vois cette
france décliner je vois cette france
menacée en proie au déclassement je vois
tellement de familles qui souffrent qui
ne vivent plus en sécurité qui
n'arrivent plus à boucler leurs fins de
mois je vois les jeunes regarder
l'avenir non plus comme une espérance
mais comme une menace je vois ceux qui
ont travaillé toute une vie aujourd'hui
avoir des difficultés dans une forme d'
absence de reconnaissance de la nation
tout simplement pour vivre alors oui je
veux reconstruire une nouvelle espérance
pour une france une france fidèle à son
histoire est sûr de son avenir vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]